Now that you've got your
analytics account ID,
the next step is to use
it in a mobile app.
For this lesson we'll use an app that
helps you decide what's for dinner.
In my family, we often have a hard
time deciding what to eat for dinner.
And sometimes it's nice
to just let fate decide.
That's where this handy
dandy app comes in.
The app's very simple.
You select your food preference,
and the app picks a dinner for you.
The app has activities for
the user to view the recipe, or
order a meal online, or
try for another suggestion.
Users can even hit a button
to say they don't like it.
For example, I don't like
anything that has beets in it.
Just a personal thing.
As you work through the Analytics and
Tag Manager lessons,
you'll add code to use those services.
The functionality of the sample app is
deliberately limited, so that you can
focus on the parts of the code that
use Google Analytics and Tag Manager.